PROFESSOR: Another
part of the course
is that I also have a
project in the course.
And students do the
projects in pairs.
Partly, because I just
think it's nice for them
to have somebody to work with.
And they've done a
huge range of projects.
I let them do whatever
project they want.
It has to have something
to do with cellular solids.
And some of them
have done, sort of,
analytical things where they've
done numerical finite element
analysis of some
cellular structure.
Some of them done very
experimental things.
And some have been a lot of fun.
So, for instance,
almost every year
there are students who
want to work on food foams.
And one year, for example,
there was a group made bread.
And they looked at sort of
the processing of the bread.
And they looked at how
if you used more yeast,
or you let the yeast
rise, or the bread rise
for longer, how that affected
the cellular structures.
So they sort of
changed the chemistry
of how they made the bread.
And then they looked at the
micro structure of the bread
that they got.
I think they even did some
mechanical tests of the bread.
So that was kind of fun.
And I think, probably, the
most interesting project
any student has done
was on elephants skulls.
So you could imagine an elephant
skull is huge, and it's bony.
So it would be very,
very heavy, if it
didn't have some pores in it.
And elephant skulls,
it turns out,
have some very
large pores in them.
I think partly to reduce
the weight of the skull,
and the head, and the bone.
The neck has to, kind
of, carry it all.
So these two
students came to me.
And they said they
had heard somewhere
or they'd read somewhere that
these pores in the elephant
skull had an effect on how
the elephants perceived sound
and the acoustic transmission of
sound waves through the skull.
And they wanted to do a
project on elephant skulls.
So I was kind of
intrigued by this.
I love all natural
history kinds of things.
And I've worked
before with people
at Harvard's Museum of
Comparative Zoology, where
they have bones.
They have stuffed bodies.
They have all kinds
of animals over there.
And I called up a
colleague over there,
and it turned out they had
elephant skulls over there.
So I went with one
of the students.
And it was an attic
of the building,
this kind of dingy place.
And there was this huge room.
And it was full
of elephant bones.
And they had several
skulls, which are
like the size of this table.
They're huge.
They're this big.
And some of the
skulls were cracked.
And you could see these
big pores in the skulls.
And then the students
found out that University
of Texas at Austin has CT
scans, Computed Tomography
scans of all sorts of bones.
And sure enough, they had
elephant skulls scanned.
And so they got a
three-dimensional
representation of
the elephant skull
through this University of
Texas at Austin program.
And then they used that as
input to a 3D printing set up.
So they 3D printed a sort of
mimic of the elephant skull
with some ceramic powder.
And they made a skull
was about this big.
And then they wanted to look at
the acoustic properties of it.
So what they did was
they suspended the skull
from a string.
And they had a speaker, and
the speaker had a sound.
And they put an
accelerometer on the skull.
And they measured the
vibration of the skull.
And then to compare it with the
skull that didn't have these
pores.
And they got the CT
image from Austin.
And they 3D printed
this dolphin skull.
And they did the same thing.
They suspended the
skull from as a thread.
And they measured the vibration.
And they could show--
and I've forgotten
the details of their results--
but they could show, basically,
that the two skulls had
a different frequency
response to the vibrations.
And they thought maybe part
of it was because the pores.
So these two sections
here are two sections
of their 3D printed
elephant skull.
I don't have the entire thing.
But you can see this is the
orbit, where the eyes would
have gone in here.
And if I turn it over
and you look inside,
you can see these pores in here.
And also if you
look at this section
lower down on the skull, you can
see this whole porous structure
here, as well.
And if we flip it over there's
a little bit more over there.
So that was probably the
most intriguing project
that the students did
as part of this course.
That was quite something.